critter junction has their eye on
reducing cold start latency and that's
going to take a bit of detective work
stay tuned to see how they profile
startup times to speed things up
critter junction's been seeing longer
than wanted startup times for their
compute engine instances
even though they set everything
according to our auto scaling
recommendations
they know they were running into some
logic on their game servers on compute
engine
like taking user inputs to spawn them
into a new critters island
but after profiling their startup times
they were seeing more than 380 second
cold start times
while the response latency for a request
was in the 300 millisecond range
they also did a performance test to see
how long compute engine was taking to
create those instances
versus how much time their code was
taking to run
this showed request provision and boot
time
straight from the cloud shell request is
the time between
asking for a vm and getting a response
back from the create instance api
acknowledging that you've asked for it
you can profile this
by timing how long it takes google cloud
to respond to the insert instance rest
command provision is the time that
compute engine takes to find space for
the vm on its architecture
use the get instance api on a regular
basis and wait for the status flag to
change from provisioning
to running and boot time is when startup
scripts and other custom code executes
up to the point when the instance is
available
just repeatedly poll a health check that
is served by the same runtime as your
app
then time to change between receiving
500 400 and 200 status codes
after doing these critter junction
noticed the majority of instant startup
time
usually happened during the boot phase
when the instance
executes startup scripts this is not
uncommon so you should profile your boot
scripts to see which phases are creating
performance bottlenecks
to get a sense of what stages of your
script are taking the most boot time
one trick is to wrap each section of
your startup script with the seconds
command
then append the time elapsed for each
stage to a file
and set up a new endpoint to serve that
file when requested
this let critter junction dig even
deeper to pull the
end point and get data back without too
much heavy lifting
or any modification to their service and
there it is
the performance bottleneck seem to be
public images
pre-configured combinations of the os
and bootloaders
these images are great when you want to
get up and running but as you start
building production level systems the
large portion of boot up time is no
longer booting the os
but the user executed startup sequence
that grabs packages and binaries
and initializes them critter junction
was able to address this by creating
custom images for their instances
which you can do from source disks
images snapshots or
images stored in cloud storage then use
those images to create vm
instances when the target instance is
booted the image information is copied
right to the hard drive
this is great when you've created and
modified a root persistent disk to a
certain state
and want to save that state to reuse it
with new instances
and when your setup includes installing
and compiling
big libraries or pieces of software when
you're trying to scale to millions of
requests per second
being serviced by thousands of instances
a small change in boot time can make a
really big difference in cost
response time and most importantly the
perception of performance by your users
stay tuned for what's next for critter
junction and remember
always be architecting
[Music]